Are there any concerns about doing too much of a good thing? I currently use
rightly right machine. The true right by input, so six days per week. The B-Burpea
MF, eight minutes twice a day. Supplements, jump on a midi tramp, walk 30 minutes a day.
Diet is okay, but could improve. I don't see any of those of B too much. Maybe you
certainly, if you're doing well, what would I cut out on this this protocol right
here first? I would probably cut the iron pro waves down. If you're not doing
well, if you're doing poorly, I would continue this protocol, but if you're doing
really well, I would cut out that thing that takes this much the most time that
is that I went to cut out by a pro wave. A walkie, the exercise course takes
time, but that's something you really need to keep going, so.